Fascinatingly,
the story of how hip hop happened is
actually the story of how innovation has
happened in kind of every dimension,
every industry you can think of,
and it's this thing called cognitive
friction.
It's the friction between different
ideas or different ways of doing
something that actually produce a path
forward that,
that helps kind of any industry become
innovative.
I was especially fascinated by the story
of the Wu Tang clan and how they did
this in particular when they got nine
guys,
nine Alpha males with big egos together
to form a rap group,
which on the face of it actually sounds
like a terrible idea.
They're different styles of rap in the
early sort of early days of hip hop.
We're,
we're kind of all over the map.
You know,
some more,
more emotional.
Others were more lyrical and they were
all very different.
And so you can just imagine the conflict
that erupts out of this.
And then they got in the record studio
together and they nearly killed each
other.
And this was because they were
essentially extensively enemies and uh,
or at least didn't have a whole lot of
trust between them.
The main guy who got them together,
his name was Robert Diggs.
He came up with this very clever plan.
Basically he said,
I will make a beat.
I'll make a song.
And then everyone has to show up and
compete for the song.
So you show up with your lyrics,
with your rhymes and you get on the
microphone and whoever does the best
job,
you're on the track or you're on this
part of the track.
And he did this and he basically
channeled this aggressive energy and all
of these sort of different ways of
operating in hip hop.
And he got them all to instead of
fighting with each other to fight for
the record and to kind of elevate this
music.
And what came out of this sort of
laboratory as like Adam smashing
together and creating this great heat in
this great energy and out of this was
born the greatest hip hop group of all
time.
That many consider it that.
And this is actually exactly what
happened with hip hop in general.
Hip Hop started with Djs throwing these
parties where everyone who showed up to
the party,
you danced on one side of the dance hall
or the other,
depending on which music you like the
best.
So the djs would bring different music
every week to try and lower the party to
their side or the other.
And this is some sort of fun party game.
And what happened is when the DJ's
announcers started competing over the
best way to sort of drag people to their
side of the party,
suddenly that turned into a battle where
week after week the announcers,
the MCS would try and come up with more
clever things to say.
And it eventually turned into this kind
of war of words and music.
And in fact also a war of dance.
And what was awesome about it is
everyone was in it for the party for
making this party better,
making this event awesome.
And people started bringing tape
recorders to record this music that was
being invented essentially on the spot.
Because it was so great and you didn't
show up to this party next week after
having lost the lyric battle with the
same lyrics,
you showed up with something different
and in fact,
all of the djs started hacking their
equipment so they could do more clever
things.
This is how we invented fader switches
and,
and things that are now standard stock
for any kind of Dj or any kind of party.
They also cracked open their equipment
and added more memory when they started
doing electronic music so that they
could have an edge in this battle.
And you know,
recently Jay z was interviewed by,
um,
by David letterman about these days and
he said that it was all about making
this experience awesome for the people
who showed up that night.
It wasn't about killing the other guys,
even if you're,
your lyrics were about making fun of the
other guys.
It was about providing a great
atmosphere.
And so this battle elevated this whole
thing and out of it was born hip hop and
rnb and you know,
all of the music that's sort of stemmed
from that.
All the culture that stemmed from that,
and that's the same thing that happened
with the Wu Tang clan.
They cleverly channeled all of these
different kind of approaches to the
music and made something better,
and I think that this is an analogy that
you can not only see in the history of
innovation in science and art and
business and politics,
but an analogy for what we should shoot
for in our own work,
for how we can get better.
That the friction that the different
approaches doing battle and smashing
together.
If we can make sure that they don't go
too far or we turn it into something,
it's about destroying someone else.
If we think of it all as part of our
collaboration process to elevate our
craft,
then we can go much further than we
think we can on our own.